but a lot has been happening last week
was a huge week and and really it was
something that that unfolded during the
three weeks we were off and and we kind
of I don't know that we saw it coming
but we were clamoring for the Washington
name to change it all kind of reached
full boil right before the fourth of
July when the FedEx statement came out
FedEx
founded by Fred Smith one of the
minority owners of the Washington
franchise when FedEx comes out and says
the name needs to change when Nike takes
all of the Washington merchandise from
its website when other sponsors get
involved team and league sponsors that
and you know what I can understand why
Native American groups a little
irritated they tried for years to get
the names change right Daniel Snyder
always gave them essentially the middle
finger and then when the sponsors get
involved in 24 hours Daniel Snyder
decides to undertake a thorough review
of whether or not the name will stay in
ten days later that thorough review
resulted in a decision to change the
name Kris you know when you think about
it just in isolation it's it's a
tremendously huge development but it's a
development that I think we all either
saw coming or firmly believe needed to
happen for years yeah I mean there's no
doubt about it and we've talked about
you know it's an uncomfortable name that
needs to be changed the time was now
because of what's going on and still
going on in this country I mean it's the
right example to be set forth by people
of leadership for this country a guy
like Daniel Snyder hey yeah you got a
lot of money and power and influence and
everything like that will do some good
with all that influence and show us and
take that Redskins name out of there and
change it and at least this it looks
like we're headed down the right path
here and hopefully we'll get a new name
soon I mean there was a few other
curveballs thrown at the Washington and
franchise here this past week but Mike
let me just say this real quick I really
want to give you a lot of credit dude I
really do because you were at the
forefront of kind of always pushing this
and really been a guy that's been on top
of it really ever since the social
injustice conversation came up
and George Floyd and everything you
started to push this too and I just want
to give you credit I'm you're a good guy
that way I mean you're a pain in the
butt but you are a good guy that way I
do appreciate very much and you know it
dawned on me in 2013 I think it was Mike
Wise formerly of the Washington Post who
was was outspoken about it and it forced
me to take a step back and say and and I
think that's what we all need to do
about that name you take a step back you
take the name off of the team we get
desensitized to what that word really is
and that's when I realized hey sorry
this is just something that has to go
and so seven years later here we are
seven years after Daniel Snyder said
I'll never change it and you can put it
in all caps well all caps never arrived
when he felt the heat from the sponsors
and the one thing that bothered me about
last Monday's announcement they didn't
just dump the name they're keeping the
name until they have a new name and the
press release announcing the name would
change uses the racial slur five times
which I know is that intentional I mean
I just did that to me I'm with you like
I read that do well I mean yeah I mean
that's just it was ridiculous I I agree
when I read that I was like wait we're
gonna change the name but yet we're not
changing it yet but yet we're gonna what
like just throw a few more I don't even
know what that is that you do there just
a few more jerk times you're gonna throw
the word out there just to just to prove
your point I don't you know that was
that was petty and in my opinion it's
called billionaire privilege via the
opportunity and the god-given right to
give anyone the middle finger whenever
you feel like doing it and that's kind
of what I think was was underpinning
that entire attitude now as the news
came that the name eventually will
change and I think it'll change before
training camp opens I think by keeping
the old name in place they forced
themselves to change the name before
camp opens there had been rumors and
there had been speculation and we're not
gonna get into any of the speculation
that was out there about what the gist
of this story was that the Washington
Post was working on and I had heard
about it for well over a week when I
first
heard about it caused me to start making
some phone calls and we were able to
report the two of the three minority
owners of the franchise Fred Smith and
Dwight Schar were actively trying and
have been actively trying to sell their
interest they're done with Daniel Snyder
they want to move on and as it turns out
Robert Rothman the other of the three
limited partners also is trying to get
out there's some there's some
disgruntled former employees and
rightfully so if the stories they're
telling are accurate the Washington Post
on Thursday
identified one by name fourteen others
decided to withhold their names because
they have non-disclosure agreements with
the team but 15 total former female
employees who claimed they were sexually
harassed with this toxic kind of frat
house culture that has existed pretty
much the entire time Daniel Snyder's
owned the team Chris yeah and you know
in a weird sort of way the franchise I
think actually benefitted from how crazy
and over-the-top some of the speculation
was because even though it wasn't quite
Geraldo Rivera opening up Al Capone's
vault I mean there's still something
very troubling that needs to be
rectified that was discovered and
reported by the post it almost felt like
a relief for the team that it wasn't
nearly as bad as it could have been
based upon all the crazy stories that
were out there but it's still something
very serious it needs to be taken
seriously and Daniel Snyder's taken very
seriously from the standpoint of putting
together a system for blaming it on
someone else and not being ultimately
accountable for the atmosphere in the
team that he owned and you could argue
the tone that he set from the top down
especially by not having an appropriate
number of human resources professionals
able to deal with complaints that
employees may have had about the
treatment that they receive but a
significant story we'll see if it lasts
into this week you know a lot of times
what happens is the weekend rolls around
and there's a hard reset and stories
tend to go away will this story linger
or will it just go away Chris I think
Daniel Snyder is hoping it goes away as
quickly as it came up yeah definitely I
you know I don't know you know I thought
when this when I was first hearing these
rumors like you that all this bombshell
stories and then you know come out I was
thinking like oh man
Schneider might be in trouble there at
ownership with the Bosch you know the
Washington franchise he might be but you
know I don't know he might have
weathered the storm here you're right I
feel like it didn't quite grab the
headlines in the way it could have or
become the disaster you know it could
have it's certainly not a good look but
I don't think anybody's like shocked
that there's a weird culture in
Washington under Dan Schneider I mean
ding-ding-ding-ding have you been paying
attention to the NFL yes I mean we know
there's there's issues there certainly
haven't like some of the things he's
done you know managing the football team
setting forth the culture
hey I know there's things he did you
know we've discussed on the show when
the Shanahan's were you know running the
Washington organization that certainly
bothered me just from a football
standpoint but it does start from the
top and you know to me I think the the
thing that's concerning to me and what I
would like to know is those minority
owners that we talked about you know are
that were they trying to get out because
they knew this story was about to come
out or are they dying to get out because
they're just and they're trying to get
her okay that's I don't want to know I
wasn't sure that Mike and then that knee
to it even more then yes it's it's it's
sharp and Smith had been trying to sell
for months and have been unable to find
a buyer because look there's plenty of
people out there have the money to buy 5
10 15 percent of an NFL team it's not a
cheap transaction but what do you really
get you don't have any say you're
signing on to whatever Daniel Snyder
decides to do he runs the show
he sets the procedures he makes the
decisions you are just there as a
glorified fan and yeah you get some of
the profits if your own part of the
equity and you know I don't know how how
great of a business decision it is for
somebody who's got that kind of money
can invest in all sorts of other things
where maybe they would have some actual
control but obviously we've seen what's
happened with franchise values they
continue to go up and up and up so if
you get in for 5% in 2003 like Fred
Smith did that 5% of the franchise has
appreciated dramatically in the past 17
years so if he does find a buyer he's
going to have a nice return on his
investment but do you really want to put
yourself through that kind of headache
where someone else is making the
decision someone who
ooh you may not agree with you may not
respect you may not like and I think
that's where Dwight Schar and Fred Smith
ended up and and here's the thing
because I first heard about all of this
that there was an effort to round up
former employees and get them to tell
their stories about the culture in
Washington as part of a potential effort
by the minority partners to get Snyder
out that's true yeah
and and I don't know that that's true
but that's how it all first came onto my
radar screen and that's what prompted me
to start making phone calls and find out
that char and Smith are trying to get
out and have been trying to get out my
point is this if that's the case if one
or more of the minority partners are
trying to launch a coup here it's not
going to go away just because the
weekend has intervened no there will be
more moves here I pointed out on Friday
hey look
it was the sponsors that got the ball
rolling with the name change right if
FedEx issues a statement regarding how
abhorrent the culture and the workplace
and the treatment of women under daniel
snyder has been and there needs to be
swift action taken by the NFL I mean
kind of like what the governor of
Virginia had to say in Virginia is where
the team is headquartered where training
camp is if that continues into this week
number one it shows that maybe there is
a concerted effort to try to get him out
and number two that it's not just going
to go away because there was a weekend
that kind of dropped in the middle of
all of this and we moved on to worrying
about whether or not there's gonna be
football this season so time will tell
whether or not this this really does go
beyond what was a bad story a set of
facts that that shouldn't have occurred
if these allegations are true and
something that will extend into this
week and beyond and maybe culminate in
daniel snyder eventually throwing his
hands in the air and selling his
interest instead of the three minority
partners selling theirs yeah well yeah I
mean you know that's the big thing that
might already the minority owners there
I don't think they're gonna be able to
sell anything as long as daniel snyder
is the owner kind of which i think
you're referring to too and you're right
i think is a huge week I would think
that Daniel Snyder's you know ownership
hangs in the balance and where this week
it's gonna be uh probably a little bit
of luck where the week of news takes us
to there gonna be other other stories
that you know you know that hit that
take away our attention from this story
or whatever may there's so much going on
in the world right now
he might dodged a bullet here and and
get away with you know all this and the
crappy culture that he's set forth and
everything like that to where it gets
swept under the rug not that he gets
away with it but right right and let's
be clear on that yeah right did this
whole thing has been set up and and and
I have to give him a little bit of
credit for strategizing in a way that
maybe helps him avoid responsibility
although I think it's wrong for him to
avoid responsibility he's positioned
this where he's got an an outside lawyer
who had to do an investigation out in
front of a little right it's gonna be
yeah the outside lawyer is going to say
that mr. Schneider had no active
involvement in or affirmative knowledge
of any of these activities you know why
the outside lawyers gonna say that
because Dana Snyder is paying the
outside lawyer and that's how this kind
of thing works this isn't an independent
investigation this isn't the NFL hiring
the lawyer who goes in to investigate a
situation with one of its teams like the
NFL did with the bounty scandal like the
NFL did with deflategate like the NFL
did with Richie incognito and Jonathan
Martin in Miami like the NFL did when
jerry richardson yes the proprietors
owner eventually had to sell for
workplace misconduct that he was
directly involved in the NFL hired the
lawyer why mike how are they letting him
get away with this do you know any
answers i don't i don't yeah and and i
was stunned by the NFL's statement now
initially on thursday night i sent
several requests to the league you got
to have a statement on this this is a
serious situation fifteen former
employees who claim they were sexually
harassed this is a big deal you need to
be saying something about this the
statement that finally made its way out
on friday morning basically said hey
look they've engaged outside counsel to
conduct a thorough investigation the
club has pledged it will give full
cooperation
to gator and we expect the club and its
employees to do so we'll meet with the
attorneys upon the conclusion of the
investigation and take any action based
on their findings their findings are
gonna be driven by a desire to protect
Daniel Snyder how how does no one else I
think people see it how does the league
not see this
that's what's unacceptable about this
I've exhausted toxic culture they
resulted in at least 15 former employees
believing they were sexually harassed at
work which is serious transgression the
owner is acting like he doesn't know
anything about it how do you not know
anything about it you've created the
culture you own the team you're there
you're around you know where you should
know what's going on
under your nose and if you don't then
then you're mr. Magoo and that's not a
good look either so I'm just you know
the more that and look hey it's a he's
benefiting from the cover of bigger
issues going on in the world right now
maybe maybe that's why the NFL isn't
pushing this or NFL's got its its hands
full trying to put a football season on
I think we all we don't need to go out
and hire Ted wills to do an
investigation because we got enough to
worry about right right be Daniel
Snyder's just benefiting from the timing
I think he is in a big way I mean I
think if this is a normal year where
there's a much bigger microscope on this
situation right now and people are
digging from every angle I do you know
the one thing that I'd like kind of
popped up to my brain here Mike and I
don't know again I'm not a businessman
or anything like that but I've been
around football and beseen a few things
in my life okay you know with like the
Jerry Richardson thing okay yes you're
right independent investigator he goes
in blah blah blah did the NFL have a
good inkling though at that time that
there would be a buyer for that Carolina
team did they know like right now are
they in a bit a little bit like man
Washington such a disaster nobody's
gonna buy that thing right now let's
hope I know if if it's for sale someone
will buy it that there is a smaller and
smaller group of people who have the
resources because the values of the team
keeps going that all teams keep going up
and up and up somebody will buy that
team if that's where it ends up I just
think that that he's dodging a bullet
just because of the times like you're
saying yeah and and I
and maybe maybe he won't maybe it's a
delayed fuse maybe it's not dodging a
bullet maybe it's just a delayed fuse
again a lot of it depends upon how
motivated the limited partners are to
get him out are they content to just get
out or do they want to get him out
because again I caught wind of all of
this stuff from the context of the
limited partners are fed up and they
want him out and so the story itself
from last week isn't enough to make it
happen obviously based upon the NFL's
reaction the limited partners are gonna
need to keep doing more and we'll see in
the coming days and weeks whether or not
they do more we'll see look hey maybe
this investigation is going to uncover
all sorts of things that make it worse
not better for Daniel Snyder if I had to
bet though I'd say it's not because the
lawyer is hired by Daniel Snyder the
lawyer has a duty to the client the
lawyer is not going to look for a way to
throw the client under the bus the
lawyers gonna look for a way to help
Daniel Snyder continue to own the team
and that's why he made the move that he
did when he did
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports